trump state department is going out with
the bang the secretary of state
connecting the dots between two of
america's rivals
in the middle east and calling for a
tough approach
from the biden administration state
department correspondent rich edson
shows us tonight al qaeda
has a new home base it is the islamic
republic
of iran days ahead of a transition at
the state department
secretary of state mike pompeo is
warning of unprecedented ties between
iran's government
and al qaeda a senior state department
official says u.s
intelligence shows al qaeda reorganized
in iran in 2015
and enjoys operational freedom and
support as iranian officials even allow
al-qaeda leaders
shopping trips and use of a pool in
tehran to swim laps
we ignore this iran al-qaeda nexus
at our own peril we need to acknowledge
it
we must confront it indeed we must
defeat it
though officials have been warning for
years that al qaeda leaders were
operating in iran
in his speech the secretary also
confirmed the assassination of abu
mohammed al-masri
al-qaeda's second in command who gunman
killed august 7
on the streets of tehran pompeo never
mentioned who killed al-masri
although it has been reported that
israeli operatives were responsible
al-masri was on the fbi's most wanted
terrorist list for u.s embassy bombings
in tanzania and kenya
during pompeo's speech iran's foreign
minister tweeted quote
mr we lai cheat steele is pathetically
ending his disastrous career
with more war mongering lies officials
say they're trying to cement
trump administration foreign policy
before the handoff to the biden team
that includes continued sanctions on
iran the secretary announced more today
the state department has announced its
suspending travel including an upcoming
trip to europe for secretary pompeo
citing the transition to the biden
administration those sources say
european diplomats had also rejected
meetings with the secretary brett rich
thank you